foreign
also it's a concentration exercise
because you need to if you tense up it's
going to be really tough
because then you're just reacting to
reacting to every
like that and then you jump around and
go go go go go go go go go
go go go come on come on
and what would you say if his biggest
strength when it comes to working out oh
it's competitiveness uh last time I did
this I laid we did eight rounds huh yeah
eight rounds eight rounds and I just
laid on the floor for 10 minutes after I
think after he started here he had a
good winning streak after he turned 30
he didn't have any wins for a while and
then he started working out here so
maybe it has some impact
cool